hey hey it's Chloe and Halle and we are
currently chillin at home and we are
about to play the sweet sister test to
see how well we both know each other
check off every detail you absolutely
know about your sister their birthday I
know I know
March 27 2005 1998 okay check it all get
off there eh you are 20 you are 21 those
astrological thought she is a cancer you
are an Aries with a complete opposite
okay their middle name of course I know
your middle in it's Elizabeth
easy there phone number yes my your this
yep easy okay there coffee order don't
drink it therefore there's no order
there forty got it right okay their
preferred pizza topping mushrooms
spinach and basil and tomato sauce and
no cheese and artichoke yes we keep the
same you like spinach you like basil and
oregano and you like garlic and red
pepper really like but you eat it all
the time
can I told you yeah you never saw them
do we not get that one I guess not their
favorite meal I you have certain foods
that you just love like white rice what
kind water is Jasmine white rice in
bread you have apples grapes Oh eat all
the time and when Apple is watermelon
thank you yeah all right you don't know
hold on you always like desserts and
he's not the favorite meal you like
pasta yeah this is not my favorite meal
she does not know veggie burgers no
first of all I have vegan mac and cheese
No
so then what is it I love was like oh I
like to eat it sometimes rice bread
similar to you mentioned Mo's vegan
cheesecake something begin you'd like
the chicken and waffles that countess
dessert and the page from crossroads you
like what you like the donut swim stage
but gluten free sugar cookies we always
put in the oven here at the house damn I
missing any day no okay hey what about
me you don't really eat dessert as much
as I do but yeah and you also eat sweet
fruits you love apples you love
watermelon their favorite movie someone
asked me that I don't know how to answer
their favorite Disney character I know
by now Terry L your urgent and Princess
Tiana Princess Tiana and we just about
to cry think you got it oh my gosh Coco
we just watched it was just the whole
remember like how they would remember
their loved once it crossed over it was
just really sweet oh say goodbye
and when his great-grandmother passed
and she finally was able to do with her
father she goes Cleese favorite types of
books to read when she does read like
self-help books positivity and Kurt told
that kind of stuff and
mystery-thriller books when I say well
we don't live there anymore you like
learning about gay shows you need a lot
of geisha books you read a lot of
fantasy books mm-hmm did I get that
right but what's your favorite book do
you have a fan of motifs too many great
books out there but I know like the kind
you like but I yeah you got those I like
right yeah okay so does that count
yeah yes their celebrity crush let's see
it's weird saying slippery questions
cause half the time we know your
childhood celebrity crush was Omarion
from b2k and yours was Bruno Mars one of
my current crushes who I like you years
back and I remember we were at the Ryan
cake premiere and I raised right after
head I made Holly get up it come with me
to say we met Bruno Mars
I'm never forget urban outfitter and in
Urban Outfitters he was hugging up all
over his girlfriend and I was like oh my
god that's right
we have to go we went up to him we were
like oh my gosh we really love your
music
he's like thank you nice to meet you my
name is Bruno I'm like I know your name
you don't have to tell me their favorite
swear word Oh what is love are you using
the f-word
yeah yours is the
where yours is no you go like there you
go I dance word I say damn more Branson
let Sally say more
that's part of the D word oh yeah the
beware yeah
Oh their favorites what was my favorite
subject in school your favorite subject
in school with science and math be
honored your favorite was English yeah
what's my favorite song you don't have a
favorite song yeah changes oh you don't
have any okay you don't either their
favorite singer or band we don't have a
favorite singer band we have influences
and inspirational like so many I don't
know yours one I know who your top
inspirations yeah okay Billie Holiday
yours is beyond your the only one is
Billie Holiday yeah everyone else you
kind of just listen to perform well
yours in it
Beyonce and Nina Simone and maggini yeah
what's the worst job I've ever had you
know I've never had a regular job that's
not fun is that safe
we're really blessed God is good we can
do it we lo because our career our job
is yes and you said you started very
young and we love music I remember my
worst job at home cleaning up the house
and doing sure I love cleaning it's
calming what's your biggest pet peeve
okay your biggest pet peeve is people
who annoy you who just say random stuff
that makes no sense
sorta but there's one thing that
literally I cannot sleep oh when I go
like this lip smacking in the middle of
the night oh I got it right hate it
Kelly says when I sleep I go like this
with my yes she makes a little like no
one hears it wakes me up out of my sleep
your biggest pet peeve are mean people
that's true you don't like rude
no or cockiness or big nose really
that'll make her cry biggest really turn
off their favorite childhood toy I know
yours and I feel so bad telling this
story your yellow glow in the dark hair
it wasn't yellow Pape low in the dark
Care Bear and let me tell you this story
well we hold on ruined hold on so I had
my precious journal because I would
always and they were scratch scraggly my
favorite journal we do identical diaries
and one day I highly highly mine near
and dear to my heart I was writing all
the time that was my favorite possession
but you couldn't tell the difference
between them so one day I'm in our room
and I see one of the diary and you and I
like I think it's mine and I pick it up
I'm like you know what I'm gonna start
writing my name on it
so that we can tell the difference oh I
wanted to customize it and I thought it
was mine witness crackles it was locked
so I did not realize it was close
I find my journal demolished so um I
said you know what and I got her
favorite prized possession now that I
look back it was pretty trash right here
and I got a risk I mean a black sharpie
and I proceeded just scribbles fraggle
on her most prized a red sharpie it was
black and guess what I could never find
another pink care bear that was
glow-in-the-dark those my favorite
prized possession I said I said to Chloe
I thought I was writing on my diary I'm
sorry I didn't know I thought in my mind
do you
then I was crying and I went to dad I
thought it was exactly I don't think
it's accidentally what's your go-to
karaoke song because we sing all the
time
you don't really sing at karaoke parties
everybody I'd much rather go up there
and go hey what's your hidden time you
have a lot of talents but they're not
really good in like you're producing
you're singing you're about the same you
know what's a hidden talent oh I know
Chloe's Legos is that a talent yes or is
that a hobby it's a talent Chloe loves
to build Legos everyone like I said
earlier she's a nerd and she built like
a spaceship she built Liberty Liberty on
a sword Las Vegas does that like calm
herself down every time I like pick up
one of the pieces to help she's like no
[Laughter]
you're not neat about it you just make
it known that know what's your hidden
talent something to do oh you can
interlock your toes I can cross my big
toe and my middle toe together like this
I see it all the time it's an amazing
talent
that was really good we got a 19 out of
22
I think we know each other I think so
too we just want to say thank you so
much so fuzzfeed
that amazing quiz this has been so much
fun and for those of you who don't know
Chloe
we have album coming out when June 5th
called the ungodly hour and we love you
guys and we hope you stream it and buy
it and listen to it and yeah stay safe
we love you guys
[Music]